-Our first guest
is a United States senator
from New Jersey
and a member of the
Senate Judiciary Committee
Please welcome back to the sho
Senator Cory Booker.
How are you, Senator?
-Thank you for having me.
Yeah. I'm doing well.
It's been a long stretch.
But it's really good
to be on with you.
Thanks.
-It's been a long stretch.
And there's a lot
going on for you.
You're running for re-election
Obviously, you're helping
in the presidential campaign
There are Senate Judiciary
Committee hearings.
How are you holding up?
-Look, I'm well.
What worries me
is about the nation,
the state of New Jersey,
and our country,
as we are in the midst
of the fourth-largest
mass-casualty event
in the history
of the United States
after the Civil War,
World War II,
and the pandemic of 1918.
And it's growing.
And to see so many folks
who are not only facing
these health challenges,
but the resulting
financial challenges,
with 40% of American familie
who have children
and food insecurity
and eviction crises and more
So, we are a country that,
for lack of a better way
of putting it,
is walking through the valle
of the shadow of death.
And it's just been
a frustrating stretch that
instead of the Senate gettin
to work on meeting that crisis
we have been rushing through
a Supreme Court justice
in a way that has never
before seen in history
when there's
an ongoing election.
As opposed to really focusin
on the hurt and the pain
and the challenges that
our fellow Americans are facing.
-I'm wondering if,
behind the scenes,
your colleagues across the aisle
feel any shame
about the hypocrisy
of what they did
to Merrick Garland
and how they're rushing
through this confirmation
with just weeks
before the election.
-There's been times
in the last four years
that I've definitely seen people
express private outrage
at the behavior
of this president,
how he tramples our norms
and breaks our traditions.
Unfortunately, with this
Supreme Court justice,
I've seen no remorse.
But it's painful
to have the actual words,
the exact things that
my colleagues said, months ago
that they would not do this.
It is one of those more jarring,
almost whiplashing
times of mine in public life
where you see somebody say
explicitly,
that they will not do this
And if they do,
"Use my words against me,"
as one of my colleagues said
And then, now,
to see it exactly happening.
And this is not
just hurting, maybe,
those Democrats who are --
who are against this.
It's actually, you know,
shredding the fabric
of our country
and our culture
and our institutions.
Because one of the great,
important things in a democracy,
for us to function,
is us to have trust.
Trust in our institutions.
Trust in truth.
Trust in each other's word
This is a time where
we don't live in a country
where it's authoritarian rule,
where one who is strong enough
gets to rule the others.
We're a nation that necessitates
grace and compromise
and a willingness
to work together
and to find common ground.
And unfortunately,
I think this episode
is going to have
lasting damage to our country.
And obviously, putting a perso
on the Supreme Court
for a lifetime appointment
this is going to be felt
for a generation or two.
-You were, of course, referrin
to Senator Lindsey Graham
and the "use my words
against me."
His hypocrisy has obviousl
been on display.
And yet, we sort of had th
hearings for Judge Barrett that,
even one of your colleagues,
Dianne Feinstein, afterwards
complimented Lindsey Graha
for how the whole thing was run.
Do you worry that the Democratic
Party didn't do enough
to show how illegitimate
these hearings were
and how unfair
this whole process has been?
-Yeah.
I actually think that we did
You know, there --
You know, a lot of times,
the things that we do
don't, understandably,
grab the headlines.
But I think that this has been
a time where the chorus of
not only my caucus of fellow
Democratic senators,
but the voices of so many
Americans, Republicans --
Heck, even two
Republican senators
on their side came and said,
"No, this is not right."
But I've been grateful
to see people on both side
of the aisle coming forward.
Even about a hundred
Notre Dame professors
saying kind things
about the nominee
but just saying
this is not right.
This is wrong.
And at a time where, frankly
we have a president
who is openly saying
he will not support,
necessarily,
a peaceful transfer of power
that, if he loses,
this election is rigged.
Telling extremist groups
to "stand back and stand by.
It's a time where all of u
should be concerned
about the coming election
and, frankly,
doing everything we can
to affirm our common value
and our common virtues.
Not just voting.
To me, that is a grave urgency
But this is going to take
a time, I think, in our countr
where many of us
are going to have to step up
in the spirit of civic grace
in a spirit of, you know,
trying to make this nation
more of a beloved community,
to help get us through
what I think
is going to be a tough period.
-You had to ask the nomine
whether or not
she condemns white supremacy
whether or not she support
a peaceful transfer of power
Were you satisfied
with her answers?
-I -- I was --
I was stunned, actually,
that there was a lot of things
she just refused to answer
things that, I can only imagine,
that in the years
preceding this,
that every appointed judge
or nominated judge
on both sides of the aisle
would find the questions
almost ridiculous.
Like, "Do I support
a peaceful transfer of power
Of course, I do.
Do I think that climate change
is real?"
That -- I mean,
a lot of the questions,
she just refused
to even express her --
her -- her affirmation of.
Was a little bit
disturbing to me.
And when it comes
to issues of race,
which is another issue
I explored with her,
I was actually sort of surprised
that someone of
renowned scholarship and writing
could not express to me,
really, any kind of critical
or even curiosity to read,
a lot of the literature
that's out there
about how our legal system
is so affected by race.
And why --
how we still are a nation
that has a justice system that
has disparate impact on people
based upon the color
of their skin
or the wealth that they have
As one of my heroes,
Brian Stevenson, says,
we have a criminal
justice system
that treats you better
if you're rich and guilty
than if you're poor
and innocent.
And so to not even being abl
to speak to that
makes me worry about how,
when you are asked to presid
over cases that I think demand
first and foremost,
from a judge,
the ability to show true empathy
and understanding
of both sides of an issue,
but yet you haven't examined
with any depth, scholarship,
or deep curiosity,
it makes me really worry
about you, in any way,
being able to make
our justice system
more equal, more accessible,
and more legitimate in the eye
of the diversity
that is America.
-I want to talk more
about race and diversity
and the ways in which the
President brings your name up.
And we'll be right back with
more from Senator Cory Booker.
Right after this.